und willkommen zu den letzten sekunden
der geister cessna die letzten sekunden
vor dem tod von peter griese mann seiner
frau juliane tochter lisa und ihrem
partner paul die geister chester hier
rauscht sie im unteren bildbereich
ungebremst auf die ostsee zu nehmen hier
also über ihr jetzt für sie der dänische
kampfflieger f16 dieser rätselhafte
geister flug der cessna eine scheinbar
führerlose maschine fliegt quer über
europa spanische französische deutsche
und dänische kampfjets steigen auf doch
in der cessna ist einfach niemand zu
sehen auch nicht der pilot ein deutscher
unternehmer und eine größe des kölner
karnevals samt familie stürzt er in die
ostsee
dieses blinkende lichter am himmel über
der ostsee die womöglich letzte aufnahme
der cessna
551 citation die letzte aufnahme bevor
das geister flugzeug und die vier
insassen in den tiefen der ostsee
versinken sonntagnachmittag jerez in
spanien
der kölner unternehmer und ehren
präsident der karnevalsgesellschaft
blaue funken peter krise man steigt an
bord der cessna kennung
strich fgr mit dabei seine ehefrau
juliane seine 26 jährige tochter lisa
und ihr freund paul peter griese mann
und seine tochter lisa sind beide
gelernte piloten nach bild-informationen
fliegt peter krise man die cessna peter
griese man schaltet mutmaßlich den
autopiloten ein kurs höhe
geschwindigkeit einstellen und
zurücklehnen nur abflug und landungen
muss er manuell fliegen ihr geplantes
ankunfts ziel flughafen köln bonn doch
bereits kurz hinter der spanischen
grenze meldet die maschine druck
probleme in der kabine dann bricht der
funkkontakt zu cessna und damit zur
familie krise man ab das luftfahrt-
produkt wird eingeleitet iphone abbruch
begleiten jets das flugzeug spanische
und französische kampfjets steigen
auffliegen neben der cs daher probieren
auf sich aufmerksam zu machen
doch erfolglos denn alle vier insassen
müssen zu diesem zeitpunkt bereits
bewusstlos auf dem boden liegen dass
geister flugzeug fliegt weiter weiter
über europa weiter auf dem kurs des
autopiloten und weiter über das
eigentliche ziel köln bonn hinaus über
rostock übernehmen deutsche eurofighter
die begleitung der geister cessna noch
immer ist die kontaktaufnahme erfolglos
die cessna abschießen eine entscheidung
die dem verteidigungsministerium
obliegt doch da das flugzeug sich
kontinuierlich richtung ostsee
beweggrund entschieden kein verdacht auf
terror die eurofighter ziehen
hinter rügen übernimmt ein dänischer
kampfjet die begleitung der cessna und
wird damit zeuge des traurigen endes um
19.45 stürzt die geister cessna und
familie krise man in die ostsee
es ist nicht das erste mal dass ein
flugzeug dieser art zum geister flugzeug
wird 1999 stürzt ein jet über south
dakota ab zuvor flog das geister
flugzeug über die vereinigten staaten
auch hier war der autopilot
eingeschaltet auch hier kommt es zum
druckverlust in der maschine
einer der verstorbenen insassen der
amerikanische star golfer payne stewart
in köln ist man geschockt und trauert um
den ähren karnevalspräsidenten peter
krise mann und seine familie
die schwedische küstenwache sucht jetzt
die ostsee ab um die black box der
cessna zu finden für die insassen gibt
es keine hoffnung mehr
und über dieses unglück sprechen wir
jetzt mit thomas was man vorsitzender
des verbandes besatzung stahl
getriebener kampfflugzeuge und
ehemaliger offizier der luftwaffe
schönen guten tag herr was man will und
was man wie kann es sein dass die
alarmrotte der verschiedenen länder die
cessna zwar begleitet haben aber nicht
eingegriffen haben also erstmal ist das
ein verfahren das seit jahrzehnten
weltweit eigentlich üblich ist dass
maschinen die wir in diesem fall den
funkkontakt verlieren
begleitet werden beziehungsweise
abgefangen werden so dass man die
kennung verstellen kann und feststellen
kann um wen es sich handelt was
eventuell passiert ist
normalerweise kann man noch visuell
kontakt aufnehmen könnte ja ein
technisches problem sein dann kann man
also mit visuellen standards zeichen
dementsprechend austauschen was
vorgefallen ist und wie man unterstützen
kann was ja an diesen trauten fallen
leider nicht mehr möglich sein
es war niemand in der kabine zu sehen
und auch niemand im cockpit also
offenkundig kein pilot im cockpit was
läuft dann da bei der luftwaffe ab
also dass endlich kommt man an den
fingern heran wie gesagt und versucht
erst mal oder nimmt erstmal die kennung
auf wann ist denn verbunden mit den
bodenstationen in diesem fall war es ja
so dass die spanier und franzosen die
kennung von max aus bekommen haben so
dass dieser schritt eigentlich für die
deutschen überflüssig waren und dann
gesagt wenn man dann keinen kontakt
aufnehmen kann begleitet man die
maschine und so lange sie sich an keine
gefährdung darstellt für personen am
boden oder ähnliche dinge beobachtet hat
man eigentlich fast einfach nur was
passiert und das ist in diesem fall ja
auch durch mehrere länder passiert in
welchem fall stuft die bundeswehr denn
so ein flugzeug als gefährlich ein und
was darf sie im schlimmsten fall dann
tun
also die diskussion ist abschließend von
flugzeugen wurde er vor circa zehn zwölf
jahren ausführlich geführt auch beim
bundesverfassungsgericht eindeutig
entschieden sodass also in deutschland
ihr gesetz eigentlich dahingehend sind
dass man entführte oder sonstige
flugzeuge nicht abschießen darf aber das
hätte ja bedeutet wenn diesmal nicht
über der ostsee abgestürzt wäre das dann
womöglich auch unbeteiligte noch zu
schaden gekommen wären
das wäre wahrscheinlich der fall gewesen
damals auch meine die argumentation ich
habe also selber ausgesagt dass im
zweifelsfall natürlich die es ist nicht
befehl das problem ist wenn sie es
befehl haben sich in anspruch aufs
ausführung mit denen sie entweder als
soldat befehlsverweigerung oder aber sie
verstoßen gegen das grundgesetz in dem
sie das leben halt nicht achten leben
zerstört also jemanden töten das ist
also ein dilemma dass letztendlich nur
die person meiner auffassung nach im
cockpit entscheiden können mit allen
konsequenzen die am ende dann zu tragen
sind letztendlich ist es ähnlich wie bei
der polizei seien mit einem finalen
rettungsschuss erstmals wird der schütze
angeklagt und dann wird herausbekommen
wie die seit den verfahren wird eine
sehr verzwickt und eigentlich auch in
deutschland ungelöste situation
vielen dank für diese einordnung thomas
wasmer
[Musik]